in this lesson we're going to talk about
function notation and functions so this
is definitely something important for
you to learn for the s80 and something
that they're going to test you on so
first of all what is a function well you
know function is written in this f of X
for more G of X H of X it's just
basically you can name the equation it's
a way of you know meaning your your
function and basically the way this
works is whatever is in the parentheses
that's your input and that's going to go
in for X on the right side of the
equation so if you have f of X equals 2x
minus 7 and they say well what is f of 3
that's telling you that three is your
input you're putting that in place of
three you know in place of X on the
right side of the equation so that's
going to be 2 times 3 is 6 minus 7 which
is negative 1 now it doesn't have to be
a number it could be you know an
expression like 7x so what you're doing
is replacing 7x okay you're putting it
in place of X on the right side of the
equation so this would be 14 X minus 7
all I do is replace X with 7 X 7 X is
the input that's going in for X so let's
go through a few examples so you can get
some practice and some experience say
they give you this first one it says h
of x equals 2x squared plus BX minus 3
now be looks like a six but does
actually be here right and that says for
the function H above B is a constant
okay meeting a number right and H of 3
equals 30 so what is the value of H of
negative 2 so go ahead and pause the
video see if you can do this one on your
own and we'll go through it together so
first of all they're giving us a hint or
telling us that H of 3 equals 30 so that
means that when we put three in place of
X right like that our output our Y value
this h of x value is 30 so let's go
ahead and do that we've got 30 equals 2
times 3 squared plus B times 3 minus 3
so we have 30 equals 3 squared is 9
times 2 is 18 plus 3 D minus 3 80 minus
3 is 15 if we subtract 15 from the other
side we get 15 equals 3 B divided by 3
and you can see that B equals 5 so if we
put 5 back in here our function is you
shavax equals 2x squared plus 5x now
minus 3 since we solve for B is five
right so now let's says what's each of
negative two so now we're saying okay
actually negative 2 we're going to put
negative 2 in for X and let's see what
we get so I'm replacing X with negative
2 and if we saw we get negative 2
squared is 4 times two is eight five
times negative 2 is negative 10 minus
three more that's going to be negative 2
minus 3 is negative 5 that's going to be
your final result so it was a
multiple-step problem here we had a
solve for would be is by using what they
gave us here each of three equals 30 so
3 is the x value 30 is the output of the
Y value each of X you can think of is
lie let's go to the next example it says
what does each of g of 4 equal if GF 4
is 2 G of 2 is three ok h of two is
negative 1 and H of 3 is 5 so they're
giving us some some values here and
there wondering what is H of G of for
now this is called a composition of
functions you probably remember the trim
your math class go ahead and pause the
video States against all this one on
your own and we'll go through it
together so essentially it's like the
order of operations you start from the
inside and you work your way out you see
what's g of 4 well for is my input and
the output is going to be 2 so this
whole quantity here is going to be 2 so
now we have h of two so we say ok here's
two if i put 2 into my H function
outcomes negative 1 so this whole thing
is going to be negative 1 so it's just a
multiple-step problem so doing a
function followed by another function ok
in the last example it says if for time
of five wise on the function f of X
equals 2x squared minus 3x plus see what
is the value of C so go ahead and pause
the video see if you can do this one on
your own so basically you know it's just
testing us on our understanding of
functions or is the x value ok that's
right here five is the Y value that's
what f of X equals so f of X is 5 when X
is 4 so I'm putting four in for X and
the y-value the output is f of X that's
five so we just have to solve this
equation for C and we've got it so it's
5 equals 4 squared is 16 times 2 is 32 3
times 4 is 12 so we're getting let's see
32 minus 12 there's 20 plus C equals 5
subtract 20 from both sides and you can
see that C is going to be negative 15 so
functions is definitely an important
concept for the s80 go ahead and review
this lesson if you need to and i'll see
you in the next lesson